oran beck says the gods tortured him for
fun he is one of thousands of ethnic
Kazakhs who have been held in China's
internment camps in the northwest in sin
Jiang region he claims he was forced to
take medicines and injections that have
damaged him physically and mentally and
he says he lost some of his hearing
because of beatings he sustained he
struggles to remember what happened but
he recalls being forced to recite
Chinese poems and rhymes everyone able
to cope over learned the song is locked
up in the dark solitary cell for days I
often heard screams in there the only
fairest one rice meal there were about
25 people in one cell everyone there had
one dream to get out he's not the only
one at this mosque in Almaty in
Kazakhstan some people claim spies from
China have tried to film them the Kazakh
government does not corroborate these
claims
al Jazeera interviewed several ethnic
Kazakh men and women many refused to
reveal their identity saying they're
afraid and fear their relatives may be
persecuted rights workers say an
estimated half a million Cossacks are
being held in camps in China thousands
of their relatives don't know whether
they're dead or alive many people have
been telling us that basic freedom of
movement such as the ability to go to a
mosque could land them in jail in
sanjiang activists documenting their
cases say they all share similar stories
this organization has documented the
cases of at least 2,000 ethnic Kazakhs
who gone missing in sanjiang year ball
says many suggest members of the Han
Chinese majority are trying to eradicate
Muslim identity after detention paper
was sent to camps where they were
subjected to ideological purification
they were forcibly taught Chinese
language and renounced religion and the
camp's prisons are tortured beaten not
allowed to sleep people are forced to
lie on the concrete floor of those who
have been freed from camps there's not a
single person who doesn't have a
physical or mental health issue Human
Rights Watch says the world must act for
doors being held in detention camps in
China there is real merit in
investigating officials who are
credibly alleged to have engaged in
serious human rights violations the
recently leaked cables published through
the IC IJ certainly substantiate those
points there's room for sanctions on the
companies that have enabled repression
in Shin doing there's known for
individual sanctions on you know people
like tantrum boy or do high lund Chinese
government officials who've been
architects of the policies but possibly
most important is closing the camps and
giving people inside the region the
ability to once again contact their
family members in managed media tools
China shows ethnic Turkic people in what
it calls reeducation camps it says most
who have been detained have graduated
and left the Chinese government denies
detainees have been abused and tortured
experts say those mistreated have no
legal recourse on the international
level we have no effective legal
instrument for the victims to require
the compensations for the tortures for
dividing their families for their
suffering or in Beck wants China to
repay compensation for harming him and
to explain why he was detained without
charge and brainwashed but he also knows
that with China's enormous power that
weight is likely to be in vain sama
Punjabi dances era Almaty Kazakhstan